In July, the temperature was high in the Chinese continent, and the
pressure distribution where the warm air was easy to enter continued,
so the temperature is higher than usual nationwide
.
Kanto Koshinetsu and Tokai have sunny days when the summer sky spreads.
It seems that
it will continue. Eating where the temperature tends to rise as inland It is necessary
to pay attention to the heavy rain of guerrillas mainly along the mountains due to this heat
. The
next news
is Tokyo Man, which has been intensifying for some time.
It's a lie that has developed into a situation. It's
unknown because of this incident. Hmm, one of them
was taken to the hospital, but he was in a state of cardiopulmonary arrest
.  20 Sites On the
roadside of the land, the rain of Mr. Hatsuka who lives in Shibuya-ku, Tokyo
Hinata Tachibana, 26 years old The
Police Agency is becoming more vigilant.
Hinata seems to be a dead
fan Ah,
yes, I can tell if you say yes
, the sound of the sun is noisy
.
Immediately after it was returned, it was displayed
many times. I just apologized for sleep.
[Music]
Hana
Aji, it's
good
.  You
[Music]
Ah,
if I didn't think it would be like this, my life
I live in a rag apartment with thin walls, and the younger store manager at my part-time job does
n't use a car.
When I was in junior high school, I was still in the middle of school.
Where did I make a mistake?
Yeah,
the moment I thought I was going to die.
No,
why are you? What are you doing
yesterday? I came to see that abstinence.
I'm not the king, but Tachibana, that's a great child.
It was number 2 in the group,
and the
only time I had a girlfriend, was that the
one who passed through?
Please be careful not to have anything for the princess or
yourself.  I'm going to the mysterious
road
What are you doing on the target road?
I used to be a musician like a consumer's mouth. It
was a ridiculous musician.
It was a book for the sea self. It was a
key word when
I was a junior high school student. I'm a junior high school student.
I'm sure now
[Music]
I was there today a year ago
--- What are you doing in Inudo? What a
real
blue magic lantern.
I'm
glad that my cousin on the
target road was in the head of Shibuya Yamanaka
.
If I've been on a business trip for 3 years, I should just give the name of Saru-kun
Wait, I can't figure out
what's going on when Yu-kun comes in
, but
I'm going to Kaoru, an image of that kind of image
.  It
's a war in Shibuya Mie in the age of 12 years.
From now on, I'm going to get into that junior high school and have a fight.
I
don't want to pretend to be free
It's quick to develop. Certainly, in order
to get into Shibuya's junior high school,
I talked to my cousin Masaru-kun.
It's burning, yeah, hey,
Sobue Bora, so I
've been in the second grade in the first year of the North
, but it's just like this in my time that I'm growing up in Barker Shingo for the first year.
It ’s not good, it ’s calm, so it ’s that kind of music, it ’s a blue magic
light, so it ’
s very detailed.
It's
a
group boycott.
Maybe these guys ate up and
got scared. Ah, that's right, haha. I remember
this performance
.
Chekojed Tea Boy Good Shiga Uun is Oichi Nenen Key Mad's Temera Gyaruo
3 years
[Music] Nunoyo It
's a
school trip
13 and the runaway tribe is
free
[Music]  ] For the
time being, I'll hit you one by one and come to you
side by side
.
That's right.
We're sticking the 3 year edition
. I'm talking to you.
I bought all of them right now.
This is
100 yen per shot of Rebeko's fist. 2
Wisdom I'm good,
so I'm giving 6 I'm not making a writing.
Was Pasiri
, I was looking good at me when I moved. I
remembered what would happen after this
.
Oh oh oh
The days of hell that are used
a lot, so all of these guys, so I ran away from my hometown when I graduated from junior high school
.
It
was a life that kept apologizing by mistake.
Yes
[Music
] That
's right. I understand the worst Soma at the end of my life
.
Manner times broadcast is Tokyo Man
Next time
,
that's right, Tachibana died because of the heights and others a year later
.
Well
,
it doesn't matter to me when I understand
it-I'm paying a touch and I'm in
5th place
.
I can't eat because I'm cut off in my mouth Takemichi I'm
just
going to the road I'm going
where
[Music]
cap
Otachibana What
kind of face did you have
[Music] Hmm
here
Ah ah ah Tachibana and Chika Ah
[Music]  ]
Ohana yeah for a period I
remember this voice I have a
good nose and it's no good at the
moment
I just
quarreled I didn't just quarrel because it was boring last week It
's okay
It's a
potted flower
[Music] It's
sunny
[Music]
I'm sorry why I wasn't there, I
just wanted to see the face of the waterfall, so there
was a lie
I want to know anything about you by saying Eh-chan. I'm
cheering
for something else.
Ako
Rubber
Yes,
I was always angry. It's
tiny and strong and
sour.
I'm damn that,
I
'm not all this, don't you lie? I'm
flying, I
don't have a roller yet
. ゐ
Ah,
Usu Station,
disqualified, messed up,
yeah, ah,
I'm the strongest one right now
.
I'm in the same
hometown, but
be prepared to be beaten, but don't be afraid,
I don't like
memos.  I
'm Naoto Chiba Tachibana
. Maybe I have a big sister,
Tachibana.
Naoto Tachibana
Yes, I'll
always die 12 years later I'm
Hanagaki Takemichi
I don't call you, but I don't like your
sister suddenly I don't like it suddenly
Why is it always
so noisy?
That's right, but take
care of
your sister, I love your sister, I love you, I love you, I
love you so much that you can't help
it.
It's just a story. Today in 2017, I fell on the railroad track from the platform of the station
. When I realized that I was dead, I became myself 12 years ago in junior high school.
Maybe it's just
gay. I'm
sure
God matched Tachibana again at the end.
July 1st, 12 years later.
Your sister
dies. At
that time,
you also die.
July 2017.  One
day Remember this day Naoto And
you can't believe that you can protect your sister
?
If this is the reality,
I'll change the future or I
'll fall to the point where I'm dead until I hear that he's dead.
I'll ask you to redo
this
mercilessness and regret
.
[Music]
I understand
[Applause] I
noticed.
Well,
this is the medical office of the station
. You fell from the platform to the railroad track
2017.  July 4, 2014
Did you dream?
I didn't feel like
I was saved in a woman's situation. May I
talk with you a little
? A
He helped
you.  It's been a long time, which is
Naoto Tachibana?
You supported my destiny
that day. You're dead. You've
time-leaped.
And I helped Kemichi-kun, who was alive and hurt.
Takeuchi-kun is time.  I swore
that I changed the present because of the leap. The giant
who swore to me
12 years ago
said to me,
remember this day,
Naoto, and protect my sister.
I studied hard
and became a police officer.
In order to protect the sound,
then
it's a standpoint. If you ca
n't do it, I made everything
.
Helping the data This is the
Tachibana school
Muragu Let's hang out with regulars today
ana I'm crouching side by side
ani
I'm
worried about your wounds at
dawn
[Music]
ni Nanda Gya Ah Ah Ah Goo me
re Alone Ah Ah
[Music]
Yoro Flirt After all
Red g Difference ani
Tauchi ai
Ah ah ah
wh
[Music]